bon
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat depuis la révision
constitutionnelle de juillet 2008 les
attributions du parlement ont été
élargies et le rôle des groupes
politiques a été consacrée les groupes
politiques ont en effet fait leur
rentrée dans la constitution vous savez
il en existe cinq ici au sénat mais pour
yvon collin le président du groupe rdse
ici au sénat il est temps de passer à
l'étape suivante en donnant aux groupes
politiques les moyens de remplir leurs
missions constitutionnelles au service
d'une démocratie parlementaire effective
c'est tout l'enjeu de la proposition de
loi qui a été débattu hier en séance
publique et que je vous propose de
revoir ce matin bonne séance à tous
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion de
la proposition de loi tendant à
renforcer les moyens de contrôle et
d'information des groupes politiques de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
présenté par monsieur le président yvon
collin et les membres du groupe rdse
la parole est à monsieur yvon collin
non pas trop même la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qui l'exercé par ses
représentants ou par voie de référendum
voilà tout le fondement de notre pouvoir
voilà toute la légitimité du pouvoir
constitutionnel qu'est le parlement
l'exercice de la souveraineté par un
peuple est toujours
il doit y revenir mieux même il ne doit
jamais s'en éloigner le peuple et divers
le parlement lundi vers chacun des
groupes politiques qui le composent le
sont également et le rdse année
d'ailleurs le meilleur exemple
mes chers collègues c'est au prix de
notre diversité que nous sommes vraiment
les représentants de la nation
souveraine
si dans notre diversité et notre essence
d'assemblée démocratique notre
fonctionnement doit être fidèle à cette
diversité il n'y a pas de parlement
démocratique qui ne respectent cette
diversité
il s'ensuit que le parlement ne saurait
être l'enceinte de qu'un monopole la
majorité exercent si on veut une forme
de monopole mais ponctuelles fugace au
moment très brève du vote
mais le parlement n'est que le lieu des
votes c'est aussi n'est pas claudio de
l'autre c'est aussi peut-être et surtout
celui des débats et des délibérations
dans les libérations tout doit être
plurielle tout va être partagé le
partage c'est léchage mieux encore c'est
le dans les assemblées parlementaires
souvent décrites et parfois vécues comme
des lions d'antagonisme ce sont avant
tout des lieux de dôme c'est à cette
condition que la nation peut percevoir
que le parlement est à son image l'image
d'une société politique ou la différence
des points de vue et des préférences
coexistent dans la communauté d'une
association politique ou importe avant
tout l'accord sur la nécessité de
délibération commune seulement ce dont
ne peut être n'importe quel dont à
l'évidence il rayonne au delà de nos
amis sic en direction de la nation le
destinateur ultime c'est elle or on ne
fait pas n'importe qu'elle donne à la
nation tout mandat électif implique
l'engagement de lui faire le deuil de
son attention mais cela ne suffit pas
l'attention qu'on doit porter à la
nation doit être une attention attentive
sérieuse
former informer le conseil
constitutionnel l'a d'une certaine
manière reconnu en dégageant le principe
de clarté et de sincérité des débats
parlementaires
de fait de l'engagement politique
réclame cette vertu qui à tout le moins
implique une forme de déontologie
s'engager à prendre soin de la nation
s'engager aussi en prendre soin avec
soin c'est notre responsabilité c'est la
responsabilité de chacun d'entre nous
mais n'est responsable que celui qui est
en capacité d'assumer ses devoirs pour
remplir nos obligations qui sont
l'essence même du mandat démocratique
qui est un autre
nous avons besoin de moyenne et nous
avons droit à des moyens il n'y a pas
ici de distinction à faire entre un
parlementaire et un autre face à nos
responsabilités démocratique que nous
sommes tous égaux repartant nous sommes
tous égaux devant les droits qui sont
nécessaires à l'accomplissement de notre
devoir
chacun d'eux c'est ici l'histoire
parlementaire est traversé par la
préoccupation et les luttes entreprises
pour donner représentants du peuple la
garantie des droits dispense à leur
mandat
toute l'histoire démocratique des
parlements et l'histoire dans
l'élargissement des moyens du parlement
et si nous respectons tous ici les
équilibres du régime politique que
dessine la constitution nous devons
admettre que cette histoire n'est pas
finie
c'est dans cette histoire que
modestement s'inscrit cette proposition
de loin que j'ai déposée avec l'ensemble
des membres de mon groupe car tout son
objet est d'augmenter les moyens des
parlementaires en vue d'exercer plus
pleinement la responsabilité élective
qui est leur responsabilité démocratique
ni plus ni moins mes chers collègues
notre pays souffre de sa politique et
nous ne sommes pas les derniers à
éprouver cette souffrance je veux parler
du sentiment diffus que semble avoir un
nombre toujours plus important de nos
concitoyens que les réponses du
politique ne sont pas ce qu'ils
attendent
l'abstention progress nous nous en
lamente oum la confiance dans les
institutions régresse nous le déplorons
l'influencé des partis non républicain
augmentent et nous nous inquiétons et
nous déclarons vouloir nous mobiliser
pour endiguer ce que nous percevons à
juste titre comme la montée des périls
les sentiments contre démocratique qui
agitent certains de nos concitoyens ne
sont pas seulement des sentiments de
déception devant les résultats d'une
politique donné il ya plus grave c'est
la paire c'est un sentiment de défiance
de défiance face aux institutions
cette défiance ne centre pas dans la
considération d'un manquement à une
obligation de résultat c'est bien pire
elle met en cause de notre capacité à
satisfaire nos obligation d'employer
tous nos moyens au service du pays plus
que jamais nous devons aux vielles 2 à
ce sentiment
plus que jamais nous devons nous
préoccuper non seulement de mettre en
oeuvre les moyens dont nous disposons
mais également si et quand nécessaire de
les réunir or cette nécessité
elle se fait toujours et encore sentir
elle se fait toujours et encore plus
sentir
à mesure que les affaires du monde se
complexifie et que les défis dont la
société attend de nous que nous les
prenions à bras le corps se diversifie
sans doute n'avons nous pas été inerte
devant la perception que nous éprouvons
j'allais dire presque par réflexe d'une
possible perte d'efficacité de notre
mission nous avons dans certaines
propositions sous ivoire le grave péril
que représente cette perspective un
grave péril dont nous sentons tous que
nous devons nous prévenir des réformes
dont je ne citerai que les plus réussies
ont certes été adopté ce fut d'abord
l'initiative sur le moment passé un peu
inaperçu mais désormais considéré comme
un exemple que fut la réforme de
l'ordonnancé organise sur les lois de
finances maintenant la fameuse rolf de
réformes d'origine parlementaire faut-il
rappeler puisque issue d'une proposition
de loi organique de didier migaud relayé
ici même parle au sénat par notre ancien
collègue alain lambert dont je veux ici
d'ailleurs salué le rôle notamment parce
qu'il a témoigné alors d'un esprit
traçant dans les attaches partisanes ou
promouvoir ce qui lui paraissait être
l'intérêt du parlement est finalement
celui de la nation permettez-moi
d'associer à cet hommage celui et qui
est encore le rapporteur général de la
commission des finances du sénat
philippe marini ça le soutien duquel
cette réforme n'aurait pas été
je crois pouvoir citer également la loi
organique sur les lois de financement de
la sécurité sociale à l'occasion de
laquelle le président de la commission
des affaires sociales notre collègue
philippe vasseur ont su défendre les
missions du parlement car chez tout à
l'heure évoqué la lolf
mais il faut savoir que le rôle joué
alors par le sénat n'a pas été seulement
d'améliorer le texte de l'assemblée
nationale il a été très au delà puisque
le sénat a ajouté au texte transmis la
3me la totalité des articles relatifs à
l'information et au contrôle du
parlement sur les voitures
il faut malheureusement être plus
sceptiques sur certaines évolutions
récentes
je reconnais que le les tentations de
supprimer certaines délégations
parlementaires dans lesquelles notre
assemblée ont trouvé des vecteurs utile
à la réflexion du parlement ont été
écartés je m'arrête je fais jouer et je
m'interroge toutefois sur les moyens
d'action des délégations
je m'inquiète des réticences manifestées
par le sénat devant l'initiative prise
par l'assemblée nationale de créer un
comité ad-hoc d'évaluation des
politiques publiques réticences qui ne
font que prolonger les échecs finalement
rencontrés par les office parlementaire
d'évaluation des politiques publiques et
de l'est de la législation en fait je
déplore que la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 n'ait pas été
l'occasion d'une véritable et si
nécessaire revalorisation du parlement
il faudra sans doute y revenir on ne
peut s'arrêter en chemin il faut aller
au bout de la logique
enfin me dira-t-on il y eu des avancées
je ne nie pas et ce n'est pas parce
qu'elles furent trop étroites qu'il faut
sans doute négligé encore faut-il pour
ne pas céder à cette tentation que nous
ayons réellement les moyens de faire que
ces maigres avancées n'en reste pas au
stade des virtualités et c'est là aussi
tout l'objet de notre proposition de loi
texte d'appel pour dire à cette tribune
il faut continuer il faut poursuivre la
revalorisation des droits du parlement
il faut donner les moyens des droits
nouveaux désormais reconnu dans la
constitution aux groupes parlementaires
en matière institutionnelle il existe de
petites mesures et qui produisent de
grands effets et de grandes
programmations qui n'en font qu'une en
longueur et comme il ya peu de chose
pire que de voir les grandes
programmations n'engendraient que
déception mais méfiance il faut louer
les petites mesures qui permettent aux
grands principes d'avoir la porte et
qu'on leur prête mais qu'elles n'ont pas
zèle la révision constitutionnelle de
2008 a été présenté comme devant
permettre la revalorisation du rôle du
parlement et de donner une large place
aux groupes politiques
ce dont s'occupe de notre proposition de
loi c'est précisément des moyens de
travail concret des groupes
parlementaires et plus largement à
travers ceux ci des moyennes aux
parlementaires on s beaucoup insisté au
moment de l'examen de la révision
constitutionnelle sur l'innovation
constituerait la reconnaissance du rôle
des groupes politiques et celle des
groupes minoritaires et d'opposition
catégorie nouvellement créé on s'en
souvient à cette occasion je crois que
personne ne contestera que les groupes
politiques n'ont pas attendu 2008 pour
exister et jouer le rôle que l'on sait
dans la vie démocratique de la nation au
parlement bien sûr mais également au
delà il me semble que cette réalité
politique est quasi institutionnelles
devrait dispenser de toutes démarches
juridiques préalables à l'attribution de
droits à des entités aussi essentielle à
notre vie politique à notre vie
démocratique que nos groupes
parlementaires mais ne voilà-t-il pas
que notre commission des lois trouvant à
redire à l'attribution par notre texte
doit conférer au groupe prétend que ceux
ci n'ont pas de substance juridique
telles que ses droits soit à considérer
elle souhaite poser le débat sur le
terrain juridique ou du moins saisir la
politique par le droit quand c'est le
contraire qui est toujours le plus
pertinent et le plus vrai j'y reviendrai
dans mon expression contre la motion
sans doute mais à ce stade je dois quand
même dire combien je trouve surprenant
que la considération à nos usages
parlementaires à quoi s'ajoute le sens
donné au dernier révision
constitutionnelle et de notre règlement
puisse permettre à considérer que les
groupes sont quantité négligeable sur le
plan juridique
finalement le problème que s'attache à
résoudre notre proposition de loi est
simple devant la reconnaissance
incontestable du rôle des groupes
parlementaires devions nous restait
inerte
je ne crois pas et c'est parce que nous
ne le croyons pas que nous avons déposé
la présente proposition de loi si une
autre assemblée active en alerte et
soucieuse d'améliorer toujours davantage
les moyens d'action et de contrôle des
groupes d'aidé et des parlementaires
je regrette de devoir répondre à des
arguments qui
me paraissent relever d'un juridisme
assez peu en rapport avec l'importance
de ce qui est en cause ici c'est à dire
le travail parlementaire et au delà
notre mission de représentant du peuple
je regarde autant plus de devoir
répondre de telle objection que c'était
une majorité qui nous a vanté les
mérites d'une révision constitutionnelle
dont elle ne semble pas vouloir
appliquer toute la logique que je dois
répondre et jeudi à cette majorité qu'en
plus de faire barrage à des mesures
simples et de bon sens non seulement
conforme conforme à notre constitution
mais que plus encore celle ci implique
jeux ludiques qu'elle prend le risque
d'altérer au sens d'un texte qu'elle
nous a présentée comme essentielle à la
rénovation du parlement et je le dis
encore qu'elle ne voit pas combien dans
le futur les dispositions qui sont
proposés à son adoption
pourrais je le pense lui être utile il
est juste de dire que la nécessité de
notre proposition de loi peut se faire
plus ou moins sentir selon qu'on
appartient à un groupe minoritaire
d'opposition ou en groupes soutenant le
gouvernement et ce indépendamment des
majorités politiques qu'ils soient de
gauche ou de droite ou du centre
les groupes de la majorité trouvent
toujours dans leur soutien au
gouvernement quelques contreparties dans
le soutien qu'ils reçoivent du
gouvernement et de l'administration et
cela est tout à fait confiance je
comprends que dans ces conditions
l'amélioration des moyens de travail des
cons parlementaire ou soit moins urgente
groupe paraissent moins 60 en tout cas
qu'aux groupes minoritaires ou de
l'opposition
mais nul n'est propriétaire de l'avenir
et autres que la volonté de conserver le
monopole de l'information n'est pas
compatible avec l'esprit de nos
institutions ni d'ailleurs avec le
principe constitutionnel si essentiel
d'égalité vous pourriez regretter à la
faveur d'une alternance politique
toujours envisageable d'avoir nelly
négliger l'occasion qui se présente
aujourd'hui d'asseoir mieux le
nécessaire pluralisme dans la
représentation nationale au passage j'en
profite pour évoquer le mur de la
séparation des pouvoirs que vous dresser
contre notre proposition de loi en
pratique
nul ne peut le contester nul ne peut
contester qu'il compte quelques brèches
par lesquelles
ménage des collaborations parfois fortes
étroite entre certains groupes
politiques parlementaires et le
gouvernement avec une prise directe sur
l'administration
n'avons nous pas eu sous les yeux encore
très récemment un exemple de cette
collaboration par le groupe de travail
réuni pour préparer la réforme sur la
fiscalité du patrimoine à bercy groupe
exclusivement composé de parlementaires
de la majorité d'administration de dell
absente de ces séances de travail
quoi qu'il en soit et la révision
constitutionnelle ainsi que la réforme
dans ce règlement constitue une sorte
d'occasions mais aussi le justification
juridique positive le moment n'est-il
pas venu de confier au groupe les moyens
de travail proportionnée à leur rôle
politique éminent dans le respect des
prérogatives positives qui leur sont
reconnus
doit-on continuer à relancer à donner
tous les prolongements pratiques
nécessaires et j'insiste seulement cela
aux évolutions de notre trois
parlementaires
si on répond positivement la cie
question alors il ne faut pas voter
notre proposition de loi mais si l'on
pense que les groupes ont besoin de
moyens supplémentaires pour exercer
leurs attributions pour jouer leur rôle
alors il faut se rallier à la
proposition de loi qui vous est soumise
elle est simple et je n'ai pas à la
détailler bout elle énonce d'abord en
principe une déclaration de droits que
vous jugé insuffisamment normative
monsieur le rapporteur mais n'est ce pas
le sort des déclarations de droit que de
paraître tel et ne faut-il pas attendre
parfois bien longtemps pour mesurer la
portée normative qu'elles ont au
demeurant
l'argument est un peu difficile à
accepter puisqu'ils viennent soutiennent
d'une position visant à refuser aux
parlementaires des moyens opérationnels
de leur mission elle contient encore
l'énoncé de droit permettant au groupe
de recueillir les informations
nécessaires aux différentes
contributions à l'exercice des missions
du parlement de ses organes qui leur
sont reconnus notamment par la
constitution
en fait il est reconnu groupes
politiques sous l'autorité de leur
président la faculté de mettre en oeuvre
un certain nombre de droit de saisine
d'autorités administratives
indépendantes faculté déjà ouverte à
différents organismes parlementaire et
dont bénéficie explicitement parfois
tout parlementaire
sam des droits ouverts par notre
proposition de loi est en particulier
les droits d'information doivent être
considérées comme proportionnée au rôle
des groupes à l'autre ils sont
respectueux des principes
constitutionnels
à cet égard la séparation des pouvoirs
qui met l'administration à disposition
du gouvernement ne dirait ton pas
parfois qu'elle est également à
disposition du président de la
république ne s'oppose d'une main à ce
que les responsables politiques ou
administratifs qui ne s'agit pas alors
de mettre en cause soit entendue dans un
échange de cette sorte destiné à
recueillir les informations nécessaires
au travail parlementaire des groupes
il n'est nullement question de donner
quelque instruction que ce soit
l'administration il n'est même pas
question de lui demander l'assistance
d'experts dès lors qu'il devrait être
considéré comme être placé sous la
direction du gouvernement
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel interdit ce que pour ma
part je déplore étant donné le monopole
des moyens d' expertise dont peut
bénéficier dans certains domaines dans
ces conditions le gouvernement
nous nous sommes donc vous le
reconnaîtrez pas à armes égales
au demeurant ces droits destinés à
l'instruction du travail des
parlementaires dans les groupes excès de
chance tricks des administrations il en
va de même pour l'assistance dont nous
prévoyons le bénéfice et qui peut être
fournie par tout organe auquel la
séparation des pouvoirs ne l'interdît
pas sur tous ces points les intentions
des auteurs de la présente proposition
de loi son père nous ne croyons pas que
la séparation des pouvoirs empêche de
nouer un dialogue avec l'administration
dans ce dialogue est nécessaire à
l'exercice d'un rôle reconnu par la
constitution
face à ces propositions notre commission
des lois c'est mieux que les groupes
politiques qui ne sont pas des organes
internes du parlement dispose de
certains droits qui sont déjà attribuées
à de tel organe convient absolument que
les groupes politiques ne sont pas des
organes du parlement
nous pourrions les ériger à sera et on
le désire ont d'ailleurs pas des droits
ouverts groupe ne sont pas motivées par
une quelconque exercice des missions du
parlement ils ne sont nullement chargé
de mettre en oeuvre
mais est il nécessaire d'être un organe
interne du parlement pour en être un
acteur
faut-il être un organe interne du
parlement pour être dotés de moyens la
responsabilité de proposer des lois ou
des débats le devoir d'apporter une
contribution utile aux travaux du
parlement contribution dans le principe
est désormais
expressément admis et dont les modalités
sont posés dans notre droit positif sont
ils compatibles avec la privatise
l'après la privation de tous moyens
d'information autres des procédures de
questions en vigueur manifestement
inappropriées dans leur lourdeur
notamment aux responsabilités des
groupes les organes internes du
parlement sont les acteurs
institutionnels particulièrement
imminent et d'autres qui à ce titre non
seulement de droit mais de pouvoir sont
ils et ses lecteurs de notre vie
parlementaire
je ne le crois pas au demeurant les
parlementeries évidemment démocratique
ça veut ménager à côté des droits
reconnus aux institutions parlementaires
des droits non seulement des
parlementaires individuellement mais
aussi des groupes
n'est ce pas le cas de la constitution
helvétique qui n'est pas en contre
modèle démocratique me semble t'il
parmi les organes internes au parlement
certains sont d'extraction
constitutionnel d'autres ont trouvé
naissance dans la loi ou dans de simples
instructions de bureau d'autres enfin
ont dû leur existence à des droits
nécessaires à leur travail pratique ou à
de simples mesures d'organisation d'une
commission leurs origines diverses ne
les empêche pas d'avoir été dotés de
droits
je pourrais citer l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques ou la délégation à la
prospective par exemple il n'y aurait il
pas quelques paradoxes a refusé aux
groupes politiques que la pratique nos
institutions est désormais leur texte
suprême
reconnaissant comme des acteurs
essentiels de la vie parlementaire des
droits accordés à des instances désigné
comme organes internes de nos assemblées
par des textes de plus modestes europe
et je passe sur les pratiques de la vie
courante qui voient ce dialogue se noue
est naturellement avec des médias
finalement l'affirmation que vous faites
votre selon laquelle seuls les organes
en terre du parlement serait tellement
de disposer des droits indispensable à
tout travail parlementaire serait-il
plus alimentaire je ne me rallie pas
elle implique de vider de tout
prolongement concret l'ambition de
diversifier et de revitaliser la vie
démocratique et le fonctionnement
pluraliste du parlement et je ne vois
pas comment notre constitution pourrait
conduire à s'y rallier
elle qui à la suite d'une pratique
constante nos institutions pause
explicitement le principe de l'existence
des groupes et de leurs rollers
au fond la seule question qui vaille est
celle ci les moyens de travail dont nous
prévoyons de faire bénéficier les
groupes sentir non raccordés à leur
place dans nos institutions
sont-ils proportionnée à cette place
répondant par la négative c'est en
pratique empêcher les groupes d'exercice
des droits désormais explicitement
constitutionnel c'est une grave
responsabilité politique si d'aventuré
cet empêchement de m'être assis sur des
considérations constitutionnelles il
faudrait y voir la nécessité de réviser
à nouveau la constitution une
constitution dont certaines
interprétations je le concède ne peuvent
parfois que laissé quelque peu sceptique
tout notre proposition de loi n'est
destiné qu'à permettre aux
parlementaires de parts à partir de
leurs positions dans les groupes
politiques de disposer des moyens de
leur mandat ainsi que de permettre au
groupe de disposer des moyens d'exercer
au mieux leurs nouvelles attributions et
pour tout à fait vous rassurer je
voudrais dire ce que notre proposition
de loi n'est pas elle n'est pas un
réaménagement des pouvoirs
constitutionnels
elle n'est pas davantage un
réaménagement de l'organisation des
assemblées
elle ne touche à rien larchitecture des
pouvoirs publics constitutionnels
pas plus qu'à vendre notre proposition
de loi les groupes politiques que nous
serons des pouvoirs de cette nature il y
a deux pouvoirs constitutionnels
exécutif législatif et il ya l'autorité
judiciaire à la chose est entendue les
groupes politiques ne légifère pas il ne
contrôle pas l'action du gouvernement au
sens formel est reconnu par la
constitution et ne le feront pas
davantage quand ils seront dotés de
droits que leur ouvre notre texte en
particulier celui ci n'est pas et ne
doit pas être un moyen de harcèlement de
l'administration c'est simplement un
moyen de retenir recueillir les
informations nécessaires au travail
parlementaire sérieux des groupes
parlementaires
si une commune confusion pouvait exister
sur ce point nos travaux préparatoires
suffirait à la dissiper et s'ils ne
suffisait pas nous pourrions améliorer
le texte en prévoyant des dispositifs
apte à prévenir tout harcèlement
notre proposition de loi ne touche à
rien je vais terminer même la présidente
non plus à l'organisation interne de nos
assemblées dans toute la mesure où celle
ci résulte la constitution des lois
organiques même
le règlement par exemple nous nous
rapprochons retranchons aucun pouvoir
aux commissions et non le confions aux
groupes auxquels des pouvoirs dont seule
une commission parlementaire dispose
comme cela fut fait par de nombreux
organismes dont la reconnaissance
constitutionnelle n'est pourtant pas
assuré
nous prévoyons seulement de donner les
gouttes des moyens de travail nécessaire
le rôle parfaitement décrits dans le
rapport de notre commission des lois ce
rôle consiste à favoriser l'initiative
législative des parlementaires ainsi
qu'à mettre au débat tout en les animant
des propositions de résolutions et
l'examen politiques publiques sur ce
dernier point pas plus demain qu'ils
allaient groupe ne procéderons au
contrôle ou à l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
simplement ils seront mieux à même de
contribuer à la mise en oeuvre de ses
fonctions par des organes constitué du
parlement dont les travaux centreront
j'imagine améliorée plus claire qc
certes plus informés plus diversifiée
j'affirme un peu de remords position de
loi est conforme à la constitution
tu es encore j'affirme que notre
constitution l'appel qu'elle exige que
serait l'initiative législative rangs
parlementaires qui ne s'appuierait point
sur le témoignage intime des acteurs des
agents d'une politique publique que
seraient les droits ménages et aux veaux
politics in était soutenue par des
informations nécessaires à la qualité de
notre oeuvre parlementaire et que du
reste et tout organe de presse que tout
aujourd'hui aisément réunir si la
révision constitutionnelle a un mérite
c'est celui de nous oblige à regarder en
face la division du travail
parlementaire
il ya d'un côté les institutions
parlementaires et de l'autre les
parlementaires considérés
individuellement ou par leur
participation aux premières nommées ou à
des groupes politiques
et enfin il ya les groupes politiques
ceux ci qui sont au coeur des pratiques
parlementaires ne peuvent pas davantage
être relégué à la périphérie des droits
nécessaires à l'accomplissement de leur
rôle au service d'une démocratie plus
vivante et donc plus forte je vous
remercie de votre attention pour ce
texte un peu long la parole est à
monsieur rené garrec rapporteur de la
commission des lois
vous avez la parole monsieur le questeur
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
président yvon collin je vous ai écouté
avec intérêt
je ne vous ai pas suivi tout le temps il
y avait semble-t-il des ruptures dans ma
conception du droit constitutionnel et
dans les problèmes que vous évoquez vous
avez raison sur le fond est un vrai
problème c'est une vraie question
je ne suis pas sûr que ça que votre
proposition de loi et était le bon
vecteur donc même si je pense qu'au fond
il ya des tas de choses intéressantes de
vos propos dans la forme je pense que
dans la forme et dans le chou a fait du
texte je pense que nous aurons y revenir
vous voulez renforcer les moyens de
contrôle et d'information des groupes
politiques
tout le monde est d'accord la question
est pertinente mais la réponse n'est pas
adaptée il répond ce que vous proposez
parce qu'elle me semble être est elle me
semble elle est contraire à la
constitution
donc il faut quand même respecter les
textes qui encadrent le fonctionnement
de la vie politique
notre pays c'est pourquoi je défendrai
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs une exception
d'irrecevabilité au nom de la commission
de l'oral en contre ce texte
alors la commission je parle maintenant
de la commission parce que nous sommes
je suis porteur de l'expression
majoritaire de la commission pense que
la proposition de l'homme quelque part
participent à une forme de mélange des
genres entre groupes et commission ce
n'est pas du tout la même chose
l'émission ne sont pas les mêmes le
parlement les commissions ont à l'égard
du parlement
une mission d'information et de contrôle
le prêt par lequel par le travail du
parlement et le parlement seule
seul le support de ce contrôle et de ses
positions politiques globales alors je
crois que ce mélange des genres vient
heurter quelques principes de notre
constitution
avant d'aller plus loin sur les
arguments constitutionnels
je voudrais rappeler les avancées vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure qui ont été
obtenus pour les groupes politiques et
par les groupes politiques
depuis la révision constitutionnelle du
23 juillet
8 et en particulier au sénat depuis la
réforme de notre règlement du 2 juin
alors dans ce groupe de travail qui
d'ailleurs comprenait le président y est
présent la commission des lois le
président frimas qui n'est pas là
présidée par le président du sénat je
pense qu'il ya eu un travail remarquable
de ce fait il n'y ai pas participé
communauté je reviens mais mais tout le
monde admet mme sûr de tous les bancs de
toutes les travées que le travail a été
consensuel et constructif dans le
respect du pluralisme sénatoriales
quelques traditions partagé que le
soyons sur les bancs de la majorité nous
y sommes d'ailleurs et ou sur les bancs
de l'opposition où nous ne sommes pas
d'ailleurs beaucoup plus nombreux vous
me permettra une petite énumération des
avancées dans les groupes ont bénéficié
en quelques années c'est un simple
rappel la révision de 2008 comporte deux
dispositions major majeur un la
reconnaissance dans la constitution
c'est très important vous l'avait dit et
la possibilité pour les règlements des
assemblées d'attribuer le droit
spécifique aux groupes politiques
c'est l'article 51-1 de la constitution
donc l'existence du groupe et la
possibilité par le règlement de
l'assemblée de mettre en place un nombre
de questions de river question de poser
de clairement la façon dont le groupe
travaille dans l'assemblée
d'autre part la séance mensuelle réservé
un ordre du jour fixé par les groupes de
position est minoritaire
c'est bien dans ce cadre larmes ce
présent vous avez pris la parole tout à
l'heure avant voire ligue il ya certains
plus l'article 48 de la constitution qui
prévoit que ce tourniquet dans le
tourniquet d'ailleurs au sénat le l'ump
rentrer mais sans que cela coûte quoi
que ce soit aux autres groupes de du
sénat qui n'ont pas perdu pour ça une
minute de temps de parole entre la
règlement de la réforme de règlement
2009 est allé beaucoup plus loin et on
peut pas dire vous avez cité tout temps
l'assemblée nationale je pense que nous
sommes allés beaucoup plus loin que je
signe
je prends quelques-uns des des points
importants me semble-t-il désignation
des membres du bureau du sénat
autre que le président évidemment à la
proportionnelle des groupes un droit de
tirage annuel pour la création d'une
commission d' enquête ou d'une mission
d'information dans un style beaucoup
plus libéral que l'assemblée qui peut
faire que ceux-ci achoppent sur un sur
un vote de rencontre prenant que des
trois cinquièmes des des membres de
l'assemblée
le partage entre la majorité et
l'opposition des fonctions de président
de rapporteur de commission d' enquête
ou d'une mission d'information
la désignation entre des organismes
extraparlementaires en tenant compte du
principe de la représentation
proportionnelle des groupes
la consultation des présidents de
groupes politiques pour la composition
de cmp commission mixte paritaire la
faculté pour les groupes de se faire un
excès de faire indexer leurs opinions ou
rapport de la commission la pondération
des votes au sein la confiance du
président en fonction non plus des
représentants mais du poids l'importance
numérique de chaque groupe
ce dernier point est très important
parce que dans l'ordre du jour et dans
le travail de la confiance du président
c'est ce que prétendent gérard larcher a
rappelé le retour du politique et il
permet de faire entendre la voix des
différentes composantes du groupe et est
ce qui vous vient que les groupes
politiques ont toute leur place au sein
du sénat
ils peuvent peser sur la confection de
l'ordre du jour tant en matière
d'initiatives que de contrôle au delà de
la seule séance mensuelle réservé à cet
égard la conférence des présidents
préserve l'équilibré entre les demandes
des groupes et ce à des commissions
entre 2009 et 2010 selon les chiffres
que j'ai demandé qu'ils m'ont été
communiquées le deux tiers des sujets
inscrits ont été proposées par les
groupes un tiers par la commission enfin
un jeu pendant qualité de questeur faut
bien que quelqu'un va marcher le la
boutique bien j'ai constaté dans la
préparation des budgets que les crédits
attribués au groupe pour le
fonctionnement ont augmenté de 30 %
depuis 2008 à budget constant chez
constant en francs courants
c'est à dire un budget amputé chaque
année de la perte de substance de la
monnaie au vu de ces vidanges crois pas
qu'on puisse achever conciliation des
groupes n'est pas été si vite
dépôt était sensiblement améliorée c'est
peut-être insuffisant mais on y
reviendra plus tard s'en vient à présent
aux textes de nos collègues du groupe
rdse
je suis comme poser une question jeudi
aux heures j'en ai parlé au président
que là il est excellent juriste chez
vous non mais je suppose une question je
me repose tout si vous me permettez sur
mon temps de parole le jeu comprend très
bien pourquoi à ce moment là vous avez
choisi le lecteur si une réponse c'est
que ça promet de ça des bars dans la
musique et c'est une sans doute une des
réponses que vous aviez présent à
l'esprit je crois que c'est une bonne
solution en parle f
ça fera toujours avancer les affaires
mais aller beaucoup plus loin dans leur
matière d'information et de contrôle
pour les groupes politiques c'est
difficile partie klein de votre
proposition ne paraît plus déclaratoire
que réellement normatif
je ne relis pas vous l'avez tous faisant
un esprit la propulsion de l'or affirme
que les groupes politiques contribuer
l'exercice des missions du parlement oui
très bien sans plus l'article 2 crée
quant à lui a droit d'accès des groupes
de sites à toutes les informations
nécessaires
fin de citation il prévoit également
l'assistance des groupes pas tout
organisme de l'anchois sauf des
autorités judiciaires
la communication dans les meilleurs
délais de tous les documents de la
transmission au parlement est prévue par
des textes et l'obligation pour toutes
les personnes pour l'audition d'où la
nécessaire par un groupe de six au m 2
en oubliant la limite qu'ils sont tenus
par le parrain par certaines règles du
droit du droit français du droit public
qui fait qu'à ce fonctionnaire ne peut
pas intervenir n'importe où n'importe
comment il est tenu il faut lever la
limite son obligation de rennes son tour
en troisième semaine ça ne se pratique
pas musulman devant un groupe politique
article 3 enfin étant en groupe la
faculté de saisir ou de consulter une
vingtaine d'organismes tels que
l'autorité de la concurrence
j'en cite que vienne le conseil des
prélèvements obligatoires
l'autorité sûreté nucléaire le conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel
le conteneur général de privation de
liberté et je cite au motif que ces
organismes peuvent être saisis par la
commission parlementaire compétente par
le président de l'adula semblait ou par
un parlementaire individuellement
c'est à ce moment là parfaitement clair
ces dispositions me semble reposer sur
une erreur de conception c'est là où
j'en arrive du rôle des groupes par
rapport au rôle des commissions en
matière d'information et de contrôle et
cetera pose un triple problème de
constitutionnalité ne s'agit pas de
monter les groupes contre les
commissions et vice et versa ça n'aurait
pas de sens
et de rappeler pourquoi les commissions
dispose de prérogatives que non pas et
que le survivant d'un groupe car cela ne
correspond pas à leur fonction et leur
mode de fonctionnement
premièrement l'article 51 de la
constitution en voie au règlement des
assemblées et non à la loi
le soin de déterminer les droits les
droits des groupes politiques
à cet égard remarque lors de lens du 17
novembre 58 relatives au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires ne prévoit
aucun droit particulier pour les groupes
la production de loi de collègues du
gardien se troue de ce seul fait
contraire à la constitution
deuxièmement l'article 20 de la
constitution énonce le gouvernement
dispose de l'administration
c'est parfaitement clair c'est une
traduction du principe de séparation des
pouvoirs qui signifie le parlement n'a
pas autorité sur les fonctionnaires de
l'exécutif en donnant au groupe a droit
d'accès à toutes les informations une
assistance par tout organisme y compris
ceux qui relèvent de l'autorité du
gouvernement
on viole manifestement la séparation des
pouvoirs seule la cour des comptes avait
retenu la constitution pas citer deux
parlements et vous avez-vous fait tout à
l'heure sur le président commission des
finances donc sur les lois de finances
et sur le budget social c'est vrai mais
il ya un texte particulier de loi
particulière au demeurant chacun d'entre
nous parlementaires pris
individuellement par capita ne peut
utiliser la faculté que leurs collègues
poser des questions écrites orales au
gouvernement pour demander des
informations ça fait partie des droits
individuels des parlementaires pas des
groupes concernant les rapports au
parlement vise l article 2 chacun
d'entre nous peut en prendre
connaissance au dur de distribution
s'ils le souhaitent ils sont à
disposition des parlementaires le
gouvernement les traces bar chaque
assemblée c'est à dire à tous les
parlementaires
ils ne sont pas réservées en commission
troisièmement et j'en viens au rôle
respectif des groupes et des commissions
l'article 24 constitution attribue au
parlement et
groupes politiques la mission de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
d'évaluer les politiques publiques
l'organisation qui en découlent confie
aux commissions permanentes ou
commission denquête aux missions
d'information et aux délégations
le solde de rentrer cette mission à côté
du droit individuel je reviens des
parlementaires de poser des questions au
gouvernement
selon une jurisprudence constante une
reprise encore dans la décision du 26
juin 2009 sur la modification du
règlement de l'assemblée nationale le
conseil constitutionnel en cours de
façon stricte un rôle d'information des
commissions et autres organes internes
afin de permettre à l'assemblée
d'exercer sa mission de contrôle
c'est ce rôle d'information de
l'assemblée justifie les prérogatives
des commissions par exemple en matière
de convocation à des auditions des
commissions permanentes et temporaires
comme l'émission d'information sont
composés de matières pluraliste
ce qui assure l'information et la
participation de tous de tous les
groupes
les commissions dans quatre centres
situés sur objet déterminé sur tous les
travaux des commissions son public pour
la publication des comptes rendus
d'abord de rapport à la formation qui
assure l'information de l'ensemble de
l'assemblée
par nature les travaux des groupes
j'utilise le parallélisme des formes
c'est quand même plus facile pour la
pour l'explication
les trois groupes qui rassemble des
parlementaires par affinités politiques
en vue d'organiser collectivement à leur
travail et leur expulsion devant
l'assemblée sont pas publiques les
groupes ne rendent pas compte à leur
assemblée de leurs travaux hier c'est
très bien ainsi
personne n'imagine que les groupes
publics du compte rendu de réunion et
rédige des rapports d'information et
c'est là que le voit que le système
divergent
à 6-6 les groupes disposer de
prérogatives francs à promettre à
l'information un contrôle ils
n'exercerait pas un rôle d'information
on de rassembler mais pour humaine en
contradiction donc avec l'article 24 de
la constitution
ces trois motifs d'inconstitutionnalité
je vous proposerai tout à l'heure on en
à condition d'adopter une exception
durabilité à l'encontre de la
proposition de loi pour conclure sur
notre positive parce que je crois que
chaque point positif dans la loire je
dois dire que je comprends et je le
partage
les infractions et les réflexions
d'autres collègues yvon collin comment
faire en sorte que les groupes prennent
toute leur part être à votre contrôle le
sénat est aussi les travaux de daisy
natif
eh bien ça je crois que la proposition
était une bonne base de discussion ce
n'est pas la façon de répondre au
problème
la vraie question je crois qu'on y
réfléchir et y travailler mais se
présente telle qu'elle soit d'un
prochain bilan de la réforme du
règlement de voir avec le président et
la confiance président donc fait partie
ce qui peut être fait de mieux et de
plus pour le problème que vous aviez
évoqué merci à porter la parole est un
monsieur patrick ollier ministre chargé
des relations avec le parlement
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la proposition
de loi de monsieur colin un des membres
du groupe rdse qui est soumise à votre
examen cet après midi mais effectivement
élargir les droits reconnus aux groupes
politiques des deux assemblées et à
renforcer leurs moyens d'action au delà
de ce que la réfonte de juin 2009 des
règlements des deux chambres l'ont
reconnu dans le cadre du nouvel article
51 1 de la constitution n'est pas
mentionné monsieur cola et je trouve que
votre groupe est bien prolifique il ya
des multitudes de propositions de lois
toujours plus d'imagination je vous en
félicite
je vous en félicite et je vois bien là
les intentions qui ont présidé à
l'élaboration de cette proposition de
loi mais quelle que soit la sincérité de
ses intentions monsieur cola je ne peux
y souscrire et
je sais le travail l'excellent travail
que monsieur garrec réaliser un point
rapporteur et je ne peux que rejoindre
les arguments qu'il a développé je vais
donc me contenter de les répéter je
remercie le président y est d'avoir
conduit les débats de la commission avec
l'autorité qu'on les connaît mais
surtout l'efficacité de résultat est
quand qu on a pu constater les
innovations proposées pour accroître les
pouvoirs des groupes d'expression
politique tel que vous le proposer en
tout cas sont d'une part inefficace et
d'autre part un constitutionnel sur le
président colin ne répondent pas la
finalité de l'efficacité du travail
parlementaire et de plus je pense
qu'elle contribuerait à créer une
confusion une confusion au sein de nos
deux assemblées entre les commissions
permanentes et des groupes politiques
bref elles risqueraient de perturber
gravement le fonctionnement de nos
assemblées
je n'ai qu'une expérience que 25 ans de
parlement mais je crois que je peux
parler de ce qui se passe dans ces
assemblées là et pardon oui mais c'est
sûr je reconnais bien bien là votre
humour et je voudrais vous rappeler
monsieur colin que tout est fondé dans
nos deux assemblées sur la
proportionnelle des groupes
les groupes sont le fondement même des
parlements et à partir de leur existence
tout est fondé sur la proportion qu'il
représente da chacune des assemblées à
commencer par le bureau de votre
assemblée puis ensuite le bureau des
commissions puis mais commission
denquête les éditions d'information etc
etc
ils sont donc incontestablement la
pierre angulaire de de l'expression
politique des sénatrices et sénateurs
dans cet hémicycle comme des députés à
l'assemblée nationale
mais le fondement même du travail
parlementaire dans le cadre
institutionnel passe par les commissions
permanentes qui sont doutés doté de
pouvoirs spécifiques de parvenir jusqu'à
très bien dit monsieur gares etc et même
mieux que moi
mais je l'approuvé totalement et le fait
de vouloir transférer déjà aux autres
les pouvoirs d un pour le donner aux
autres aussi créé une confusion et une
perturbation grave de du fonctionnement
de nos institutions
je ne suis pas certain que ce soit à
cela que vous souhaitiez arrivé à
monsieur koné je suis pas certain je
suis même certain du contraire je suis
même certain du contraire
donc vous avez peut-être réfléchir et
voté avec que de l'exception des
réservistes et tout à l'heure quand on
va avoir à défendre cette proposition de
loi intervient alors en plus ce
président koné en plus de ces si j'ai du
respect pour votre personne et pour le
groupe que vous représentez des cas même
quand même la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 qui a été adopté à l'initiative
du président de la république et du
premier ministre a revu le rôle du
parlement l'a profondément cette
révision renforcer le rôle de nos deux
assemblées
monsieur colin et oui oui et elle a
largement donné les pouvoirs que l'on
pouvait espérer pouvoir donner en plus
aux groupes politiques tel que vous le
souhaitez en particulier l'initiative
parlementaire occupe davantage de place
dans l'ordre du jour des assemblées et
c'est bien à cause de cette initiative
parlementaire qu'aujourd'hui
qu'aujourd'hui nous allons passer
agréablement deux heures ensemble à
discuter de cela monsieur cola et vous
avez oublié de remercier la majorité
d'avoir voter cette réforme
constitutionnelle qui vous donne
aujourd'hui le moyen de vous exprimer en
tant que président de groupe
monsieur colle à la fonction de contrôle
et d'évaluation des politiques publiques
est le site est consacré à l'article 24
de la constitution tout en renforçant
ainsi la place du parlement
le constituant a énoncé des règles
précises pour établir un nouvel
équilibre entre la majorité
les groupes d'opposition
les minoritaires là aussi c'est bien des
groupes dont il s'agit monsieur colin
les groupes sont dorénavant partie
prenante à l'élaboration de l'ordre du
jour des assemblées article 48 c les
groupes peuvent désormais être à
l'origine d'une déclaration du
gouvernement article 51 1 c pour le
reste l'article 51 de la constitution
renvoie aux règlements des assemblées et
quoi de plus démocratique si ce n'est
cette disposition qui donne à chacune
des assemblées le soin de définir le
rôle qui leur est imparti
je parle des groupes dans le
fonctionnement de du parlement
c'est-à-dire de chacune des deux
assemblées
je pense que là c'est un processus
efficace et est tout à fait transparent
et démocratique ensuite entre 2009 et
2011 l'assemblée ont poursuivi cette
démarche
elles ont notamment tiré toutes les
conséquences cette révision
constitutionnelle dans leur règlement au
début de cette année d'ailleurs la loi a
permis de mettre en place il cette île
du président a accueilli un nouveau
dispositif de contrôle et d'évaluation
des politiques publiques choisies y est
c'est quelque chose lancre de cette
dernière loire est à peine sèche que
déjà monsieur colin les auteurs de la
proposition de loi suggère qu'il
faudrait revenir se dérègle nouvelle que
les assemblées s'applique à mettre à
neuf avec difficulté mais s'applique
consciencieusement à mettre en oeuvre
alors patience chaque jour nous révèle
les effets des réformes engagées depuis
permettez-moi de m'interroger sur le
calendrier dans lequel intervient cette
proposition qui est dans le sentiment de
rouvrir des débats très récemment
tranché dans chacune de nous deux
assemblées quant au contenu même de la
proposition de loi je ne vois pas ce
qu'apportent l'article premier monsieur
colin les groupes politiques des
assemblées participent dores et déjà à
la vie démocratique de la nation en
contribuant à l'exercice des différents
pouvoirs attribués au parlement comme je
viens de l'expliquer surtout je crois
devoir souligné qu'à la différence des
droits déjà reconnu au groupe dans les
règlements des assemblées des
innovations que vous proposez nous
répondent la plupart d'entre elles pas
trait à l'organisation interne des
travaux des assemblées mais à
l'affirmation des groupes comme acteur à
part entière de relations entre les
pouvoirs publics et là tout change
tel est le cas de l'article 2
de la proposition de loi en ce qu'il
prévoit que les groupes pourrait
demander l'assistance de tout organisme
pouvant les aider à contribuer à
l'exercice de la mission législative et
de la mission de contrôle du parlement
et lorsqu'il investir et les groupes du
pouvoir d'auditionner toute personne et
les vrais le secret professionnel dans
le cadre de ces auditions
ça c'est du ressort des commissions
permanentes monsieur le présent comme
tel le cas de l'article 3 également
da propositions en ce qu'il donnerait à
chaque groupe non droit de saisine des
diverses instances c'est petit c'est
identique d'ailleurs notamment des
autorités administratives et
indépendante
au passage je rappelle que les
présidents de groupe parfaitement
inviter des personnes qu'ils souhaitent
auditionner on a jamais aucune aucun
élément en tout cas des institutions le
leur a interdit de le faire un signe
tangible que de ce qu'est ces
innovations sont perçus par leurs
auteurs comme une nature différente de
celle intervenue en 2009 par leur
refonte des règlements des assemblées et
d'ailleurs il formule ici une
proposition de loi plutôt qu'une
proposition de résolution visant à
réformer le règlement du sénat et la
démarche que vous avez choisie indique
clairement la nature de votre objectif
pour toutes ces raisons cette
proposition de loi se heurte des
objections juridiques déterminante
tout d'abord dû être rapide
l'affirmation d'un droit des groupes à
requérir l'aide des administrations est
contraire à ce qu'il paraît constituer
un principe à valeur constitutionnelle
à savoir la neutralité d'administration
monsieur cola au terme l'article veulent
la constitution le gouvernement dispose
de l'administration
la loi peut dans certaines mesures
aménager cette règle pour donner au
parlement et à ces instants de certaines
facilités mais il faudrait une
habilitation constitutionnel explicites
pour que les groupes puissent disposer
l'administration qu'il s'agisse de
services placés sous l'autorité du
gouvernement ou des autorités
administratives indépendantes
je pense que le président y est en plein
de commissions sais de quoi je parle
c'est un sujet qui perturbe souvent je
reconnais l'avis des commissions et des
présidents il ya t est assez longtemps
pour savoir de quoi je parle
à cet égard la formulation article cas
de la constitution
et bien trop générale pour que l'on
puisse y voir un fondement possible à
votre proposition de loi le lien entre
la proposition de loi et la
participation à la vie démocratique est
en effet bien trop de tenue quant à
l'article 51 non seulement il est
inopérant
mais il montre bien contrario ce qu'a
voulu faire le constituant pour les
groupes des aménagements internes au
fonctionnement des assemblées
rien de plus aucune des dispositions
constitutionnelles relatives au groupe
ne permet donc de considérer que le
constituant aurait entendu en faire des
acteurs à part entière du fonctionnement
des pouvoirs publics au delà des cas
qu'elle détermine pour ces raisons la
proposition de loi me semble contraire à
la constitution monsieur le présent
colloque
permettez moi d'ajouter qu'en ce domaine
qui ne tient pas la modification des
règles dans lesquelles se déroulent
travail parlementaire
on le sait la pratique est aussi une
source de progrès je cite l exemple
modestement avant la réforme
constitutionnelle de 2008 2006 en tant
que présente commission j'inaugure et la
formule des cours à porter associé à un
membre de la majorité est un membre de
l'opposition pour le contrôler
l'exécution d'une loi
personne ne m'a empêché de le faire à
l'assemblée nationale et je les fais et
c'est à partir cette pratique ensuite
s'est introduit dans les nouvelles
dispositions qui ont été prises car je
considère à titre personnel mais je suis
pas le seul à partager cet avis que
s'agissant de l'exécution des lois
l'opposition doit être associée au
contrôle exercé par la majorité
cette formule a montré tout son intérêt
pour donner aux groupes minoritaires
un rôle important dans le contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et la réforme
engagée par la constitution a confirmé
toutes ses dispositions
et puis je dois vous dire le plus
important j'y reviens pour moi et la
confusion que vous risqueriez de créer
avec le travail des commissions
car cela est essentiel pour
député au port un sénateur et
je pense que si les groupes sur la
pierre angulaire du fonctionnement des
assemblées
les commissions sont le garant de
l'expression de ces groupes puisque
c'est à travers elle qu'ils peuvent
formuler toute demande à due proportion
bien sûr puisqu'il y a une règle et
ussel d'une majorité est celle d'une
minorité dans toute assemblée
démocratique démocratiquement élu donc
je reviens sur ce que je disais ce
transfert de pouvoirs n'était pas
souhaitable et ne serait créé que de la
confusion et mettre à mal l'équilibré de
la constitution comme cela a d'ailleurs
été signée dans le rapport jeudi on vous
l'a attribuée au groupe des prérogatives
propres commission en matière
d'information de contrôler denquête ce
texte repose fondamentalement sur une
erreur de conception des rôles des
groupes par comparaison celui des
commissions je tiens à dire et à rendre
à nouveau hommage à votre président de
commission monsieur y est il est à
souligner la qualité et la pertinence du
rapport de votre rapporteur monsieur
guirec
alors monsieur que les y ai confiance en
la prérogative dans les prérogatives que
d'ores et déjà le règlement vous
reconnaît en tant que président de roeck
du groupe exerçait déjà les prérogatives
qui vous sont reconnus et vous le faites
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui avec beaucoup de
compétence dans le cas de cette
proposition de loi
je crois pour ma part que toutes les
innovations introduites depuis 2008 sont
en train de produire leurs effets il
appartient à chaque parlementaire de
faire en sorte de deux pour chaque
groupe vous constituer dans chacune il a
semblé d'en tirer le meilleur parti
maintenant pour les innovations que vous
proposez une auraient pour la plupart
d'entre elles pas trait à l'organisation
interne des travaux
vous m'excuserez je suis en train de
mélanger pas je demande discours j'ai
tellement été passionné monsieur
monsieur colin à ce que j'avais à vous
dire que j'ai bien mangé des pâtes beaux
discours
pardonnez moi donc j'ai pas vous
infliger à nouveau j'ai pas vous
infliger à nouveau la lecture de ce que
je viens de vous dire
donc je vous disais d'avoir confiance
d'avoir confiance aux prérogatives que
le règlement vous reconnaît déjà et je
pense qu'à partir de là on peut trouver
un bon équilibre entre le fonctionnement
des commissions le fonctionnement des
groupes c'est à dire un bon équilibre
pour le fonctionnement des institutions
et en conclusion mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs le gouvernement souhaite
que la majorité rejette cette
proposition de loi
en tout état de cause souhaite que tout
à l'heure elle puisse voter l'exception
d'irrecevabilité présenté par la
commission je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur jean pierre
sueur pour le groupe socialiste
c'est trop
il a pris tout le temps du groupe
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
c'est toujours un plaisir que de
débattre des propositions de loi
présentées par le groupe
rds eux et particulièrement par monsieur
cola et vous savez monsieur colin que
nous avons eu l'occasion de soutenir
beaucoup de vos initiatives
cette fois ci je voulais vous dire que
vous avez raison de poser la question du
rôle des groupes politiques au sein des
assemblées parlementaires
c'est un vrai sujet c'est un bon sujet
nous ne partageons pas la totalité de
vos propositions mais je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi monsieur colin je
pense voyez vous que dans ce qui a été
dit par les orateurs précédents
il y a une part de vérité celle ci tient
tant à l'idée que nous nous faisons de
l'état voyez vous il est arrivé à
certains d'entre nous ici d'exercer des
fonctions au sein de gouvernement et
peut-être les éminents représentants du
rdse vais peut-être vous même monsieur
le président aurez-vous à la faveur
d'une alternance que nous pourrions
souhaité cette possibilité et dans ce
cas là je ne suis pas sûr que le membre
du gouvernement que que vous seriez
serait tout à fait en accord avec le
fait que l'un ou l'autre des groupes
parlementaires ont pu convoquer eu de
recherche son directeur général de
l'administration son directeur de
cabinet voir monsieur le préfet monsieur
le sous-préfet pour rendre des comptes
autant autant je pense qu'il est juste
que cela soit l'apanage des commissions
d'enquêté parlementaires devant
lesquelles
quiconque doit venir s'exprimer à
l'exception du président de la
république en vertu de notre
constitution
autant je crois qu'il serait peu adapté
de confier à chaque groupe parlementaire
les mêmes prérogatives
donc je tenais à vous dire cela
amicalement et franchement puisque je le
pense mais cela étant dit monsieur le
président de la commission des lois et
monsieur le rapporteur notre groupe ne
souscrira pas je ne veux pas vous
désobliger mais ne ce que souscrira pas
à l'exception d'irrecevabilité
car lorsque vous déposez cette exception
d'irrecevabilité vous dites en quelque
sorte et en langage juridique ce n'est
pas la peine de parler de cela ce n'est
pas utile ce n'est pas le lieu ce n'est
pas conforme à la constitution
alors que me semble t'il
il y a dans l'initiative de monsieur le
président cola des choses utiles et en
tout cas une démarche que pour ma part
je salue et comme il faut être positif
monsieur le ministre j'ai vu qu'une fois
encore vous savez quelque peu donné dans
l'autosatisfaction
tout ne va pas pour le mieux dans le
meilleur des mondes et je voudrais à
sortir ce propos et cette explication de
vote pourquoi nous pensons qu'il
regrettable de ne pas se saisir de cette
proposition de loi vous eussiez peu plus
monsieur le ministre l'amendé par
exemple suite était tout à fait possible
c'est à cela que sert le parlement
monsieur le président vous eussiez pu
tout également la mambé et je voudrais
et je voudrais faire pour arriver
toujours à plus de démocratie la
démocratie comme la république et je
parle devant jean pierre chevènement
mais pas lui seul car nous sommes tous
attachés à la république demande à être
toujours toujours parfaite
nous n'avons pas déposé d'amendement
monsieur le ministre
parce que ayant participé à la
commission
nous avons vu que d'autres chefs le
couperet de l'exception d'irrecevabilité
s'abattrait et nous n'avons pas voulu
travailler inutilement
mais puisque la question des groupes
politiques a été posée je voudrais me
permettre de faire du haut de cette
tribune quatre suggestions
la première monsieur garrec a beaucoup
dit qu'il y avait une répartition
proportionnelle des postes au bureau du
sénat que les choses avaient changé à la
conférence des présidents
c'est vrai toutefois il y avait une
chose qui n'a pas changé
et bien voilà monsieur le président de
la commission des lois
vous en êtes tellement convaincu vous
même que vous le dites
avant que je le dise moi même je vous
remercie
je vous remercie parce que cela montre
que vous avez vous avez vous avez une
habitude de ma pensée va encore qu'il
soit tout à fait présomptueux de parler
de penser mais toujours est il que je
trouve profondément anormal que sur hui
commission permanente du sénat
huit sur huit soit présidée par des
représentants des groupes politiques de
la majorité
je trouve cela profondément anormal et
il y à de très nombreux parlements de
par le monde dans des pays démocratiques
naturellement où l'on jugerait cela
incongru quelles difficultés y aurait-il
à ce que des représentants des groupes
de la minorité madame la présidente vous
présidez et nous avons l'honneur d'avoir
des vice présidents du sénat qui
appartiennent à tous les groupes et
pourquoi n'y aurait-il pas des
présidents de commissions et de la même
manière je trouve que sauf exception
notable que vous connaissez très bien
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois dont je ne vais pas les
rappeler mais je trouve quand même
dommage
qu' un nombre très important de rapports
pour ce qui est des projets de loi je
dis bien des projets de loi soit confiée
à des représentants de la majorité
je trouve qu'il serait tout à fait
équitable que ceux ci furent répartis
entre la majorité et l'opposition
le rapporteur il a pour mission de
rapporter la position de la commission
mais je trouve que c'est très bien
je me souviens tout à fait de tel ou tel
député qui a dû disparaître
malheureusement qui disait
solennellement
las la commission a suivi n'a pas suivi
son rapporteur qui pensait mais voilà il
a expliqué la position de la commission
il était chargé de l'expliquer et là je
pense qu'il y aurait un progrès pour nos
institutions donc faire confiance aux
collègues de tous les groupes politiques
pour rapporter la position de la
commission est aussi pour présider la
commission c'est ma première suggestion
elle est parfaitement conforme à la
constitution elle est conforme au
règlement du sénat et je pense monsieur
le ministre que vous y verrez beaucoup
de points positifs
en second lieu je voulais parler des
questions les questions parlementaires
je trouve que nos questions sont quelque
peu figé les questions les questions
d'actualité mais d'un bourreau par
exemple nous venons d'assister à cette
séance bien elle fut courtoise comme
souvent au sénat mais voyez vous il nous
arrive que nous posons une question
pendant 2 minutes 30
le gouvernement répond par une parfaite
langue de bois cela peut arriver ou hors
du sujet pendant 2 min 30 terminé on ne
peut rien dire
les questions du mardi nous donne dans
une certaine convient tente
confidentialité mais enfin tout le monde
peut lire le journal officiel ou
regarder le site internet du sénat
la possibilité de répliquer mais une
fois que nous avons répliqué
que se passe-t-il et si la chose ne nous
convient pas nous pouvons toujours posé
une question écrite et si au bout de six
mois le ministre n'a pas répondu
et bien que se passe-t-il à rien nous
pouvons reposer la question et ne se
passe toujours rien monsieur le
président du sénat a fait une innovation
avec des questions cribles mais je pense
que cela n'est pas très concluant et je
voudrais faire des suggestions je pense
que nos amis britanniques ont des
pratiques qui sont très intéressantes
c'est à dire que le ministre et là vous
voyez monsieur ollier vous êtes là et
pendant une heure les parlementaires
pose les questions et reprennent la
parole s'il le faut dit foire dans
monsieur le ministre vous n'avez pas
répondu je reviens sur ma question je
vous demande précisément ceci cela je
sais que lorsque l'on est membre du
gouvernement
cela n'est pas très confortable enfin si
on veut vivre dans le confort il ne faut
pas être membre du gouvernement en tout
cas c'est l'idée que je m'en fais donc
je pense que la procédure des questions
pourraient être une procédure davantage
nerveuse davantage contradictoires et
permettant d'approfondir les sujets
tandis que là qu'une fois que chacun a
dit finalement ce qu'il avait à dire on
se quitte sans avoir suffisamment
approfondi la question je voulais faire
une troisième suggestion
en ce qui concerne les semaines la
première c'était la présidence et les
rapports monsieur le président la
seconde c'est pour une conception plus
nerveuse des questions la troisième pour
ce qui est de la semaine de contrôle et
l'initiative
bien sûr nous nous louons du fait que
cette semaine existent et vous ne
manquerez pas d'expliquer le vote sur la
constitution
nous connaissons le discours mais je
crois que là aussi il faut améliorer le
système parce que l'expérience de
plusieurs mois nous montre que nous
assistons à une grande succession de
débats quelque peu platonique
encore que
il est fâcheux d'embarquer un grand
penseur comme platon dans cette affaire
monsieur le président je vous en
convient j'en conviens mais deux débats
quelque peu abstrait on parle d'un sujet
pendant une heure une heure et demie et
puis il ne se passe rien lorsqu'on en a
parlé
en effet mel c'est très intéressant mais
je pense que le parlement a aussi et
principalement pour mission de faire la
loi
et s'agissant des propositions de loi le
système à mon avis mais très être
améliorée car nous assistons à beaucoup
de débats ont commencé à examiner des
propositions de loi qu'ils ne vivent en
aucun cas une vie parlementaire avec une
navette c'est à dire que je voudrais
qu'on fasse l'inventaire de toutes les
propositions de lois mort nés dont on a
parlé une fois sans que cela ait
quelques effets si bien que lorsque l'on
veut faire avancer un sujet est bien en
effet et nous pouvons tous en convenir
il est plus facile d'avoir recours à un
amendement à une loi de simplification
du droit par exemple car une proposition
de loi inscrits dans un créneau
parlementaire c'est plus efficace c'est
tout à fait évident et je ne prendrai
qu'un exemple celui de ce matin
ce matin il y avait deux textes inscrits
à l'ordre du jour le premier a beaucoup
débordé monsieur le ministre vous avez
d'ailleurs contribué aux débordements si
je puis dire en nous en nous faisant
part de vos de vos opinions sur la
fiscalité
pendant une période qui était très
conséquente
oui trente minutes mais je nous fais
remarquer que si vous aviez parlé par
exemple 15 minutes mais c'est pas moi
qui veux vous dire qu'il faut être court
enfin 15 minutes monsieur le ministre
cela oui il nous reste trois minutes 43
cela monsieur le ministre nous aurait
permis d'achever parce qu'il a manqué un
quart d'heure l'examen de la proposition
de résolution sur la laïcité il a manqué
exactement un quart d'heure et on est
arrivé à 13 heures peut-être 20 minutes
ou une demi-heure madame la présidente
toujours est il que cette proposition
importante qui aurait sans doute été
votée ne l'a pas été faute que nous
soyons dans la capacité de maîtriser
l'ordre du jour de ces séances réservées
mais je dis ça en m'adressant à tout le
monde je dis monsieur le président et
c'est ma troisième suggestion qu'il
serait bien que nous réfléchissions afin
de parfaire ce système est de lui donner
une plus grande efficacité
ma quatrième suggestions je les ai déjà
fait gelé déjà fait monsieur le
président ma quatrième suggestions c'est
vraiment de donner aux groupes
politiques et par conséquent aux
parlementaires plus de pouvoirs en
matière d'application des lois et à cet
égard je ne saurais trop regretter comme
l'a fait l'autre jour monsieur jean rené
lecerf qui était le rapporteur que la
précédente proposition de loi de
monsieur colin à laquelle on ne rendra
jamais trop hommage
pour permettre aux parlementaires que
nous sommes de saisir le conseil d'état
en cas de non-application de la loi que
nous avons voté en tant que
parlementaire parce que tout simplement
le gouvernement s'est refusé à publier
les décrets et bien je regrette que
cette proposition soit restée lettre
morte qu'elle n'ait pas été approuvé par
le sénat je conclus il y a des moyens
très simples et j'ai voulu être concret
d'améliorer le rôle des groupes
politiques dans un meilleur partage des
fonctions de président ses deux
rapporteurs avec une procédure plus
nerveuse plus démocratique et plus
réactives pour les questions en revoyant
l'organisation des semaines de contrôle
et d'initiatives et en nous permettant
enfin d'agir avec efficacité pour que
les lois votées bénéficie effectivement
d'une application
merci monsieur le sénateur
la parole est à madame la présidente
nicole borvo cohen seat pour le groupe
crc spg
c'est après madame gouro désolé bonjour
à bas chaque lit trop x est à toi à
merci madame la présidente monsieur
ministre chers collègues je crains
d'avoir une approche différente des uns
et des autres mais ça permet l'échangé
s'est ramassé tout à fait important au
parlement
en effet bon notre collègue yvon collin
qui a le mérite d'avoir fait cette
proposition de loi dit que les groupes
ont trouvé place expressément au sein de
la constitution lors de la révision voté
à versailles le 23 juillet 2008
oui mais cette reconnaissance sa
compagne est quand même ou accompagné
je ne sais pas comment dire une
tentative de faire passer cette révision
pour ce qu'elle n'était pas à notre sens
c'est à dire un renforcement des droits
du parlement
notre groupe a de la constance nos
prédécesseurs se sont opposés à la
constitution de 58
parce qu'elle porte en germe la
présidentialisation de nos institutions
et la subordination du parlement à
l'exécutif et les évolutions de pluie et
plusieurs gouvernements se sont succédés
n'ont fait que confirmer est en quelque
sorte aggravé cette logique avec mes
amis nous avons eu de cesse de souligner
le recul du pouvoir législatif face au
pouvoir exécutif que la loi
constitutionnelle de 2008 n'a pas du
tout remis en cause mais disons
continuer d'entériner l'hyperprésidence
de nicolas sarkozy depuis trois ans a
confirmé la difficulté croissante que
rencontre le parlement avant
pire deux missions essentielles à nos
yeux représenter les citoyens et faire
la loi
le divorce entre les citoyens et ses
représentants d'ailleurs qui est
aujourd'hui particulièrement inquiétant
est préoccupant donc concernant le
parlement c'est ce qui doit nous
préoccuper le plus le partage de l'ordre
du jour présentée comme le point d'orgue
du renforcement du pouvoir des
assemblées a surtout d'une part permis à
la majorité parlementaire quand même
d'accompagner les initiatives du
gouvernement
vu le nombre de propositions à
l'initiative de la majorité qui
n'étaient en fait que des projets de loi
recycler pour des raisons
conjoncturelles et opportuniste
d'ailleurs pour lui faire passer pour
être clair son manifeste et de plus
comme il n'est pas possible d'examiner
la question institutionnelle en dehors
du contexte politique
comment ne pas constater que
l'initiative propre du parlement dans le
cadre d'une inflation législative du
gouvernement en renforcer d'une
législation d'affichage d'opinion qui
met une pression permanente sur
l'institution parlementaire ne peut au
fond ne peut que dégrader la qualité de
l'intervention delà du rôle du parlement
en permanence l'adage trop de lois tuent
la loi et chaque semaine vérifié depuis
plusieurs années comme l'a souligné
d'ailleurs le rapport de la commission
des lois sur l'application des lois
l'initiative parlementaire le fameux
droit de tirage se trouve quand même
soyons francs marginalisée par cet
activisme législatif du gouvernement et
donc du pouvoir de dire ah ben je
préfère dire et de surcroît d'ailleurs
un peu méprisé en particulier à
l'assemblée nationale par la majorité
parlementaire
le dépôt systématique de motions de
procédure et on le voit encore
aujourd'hui sur les textes déposés par
l'opposition confirme cette conception
réductrice
de l'initiative parlementaire se dire il
n'y a pas d'équivalence entre
l'initiative des parlementaires et les
projets du gouvernement
donc comment parler de renforcement des
pouvoirs des groupes politiques
les groupes qui sont effectivement
source de structuration du débat
politique alors que le régime par
exemple à l'assemblée nationale du
crédit temps réduit de plus en plus les
débats à l'assemblée à des déclarations
de principe
abandonnant le travail législatif aux
commissions au sénat l'équilibré des
forces politiques n'a pas permis une
telle restriction du débat démocratique
malgré des tentatives de la majorité et
certains j'en suis sûr le regrette mais
enfin cela est comme ça même si
l'utilisation extensive excessive de
l'article 40 le développement de la
règle dite de l'entonnoir limitant le
dépôt d'amendements seconde lecture ou
l'épée de damoclès de l'irrecevabilité
dit règlementaire de l'article 41 de la
constitution bride petit à petit la
place des dupes à des groupes
parlementaires dans le travail
d'élaboration législatives cette
description de l'évolution négative
selon nous du travail parlementaire qui
n'était pas dû à 2008 mais qui n'a pas
été infirmé par 2008 vise à souligner
que les propositions du groupe
rds ceux concernant l'activité de
contrôle des groupes donc du parlement
sont peu compatibles avec les rapports
actuels entre exécutif et législatif
pour notre groupe la question est
ailleurs
elle est dans le déséquilibre
aujourd'hui entre législatif et exécutif
inhérents à la logique présidentialiste
les auteurs du texte indique dans
l'exposé des motifs qu'il est temps de
passer à l'étape suivante en donnant aux
groupes politiques et les moyens de leur
mission constitutionnelle au service
d'une aide
démocratie parlementaire effectués je ne
peux être en accord avec cette approche
qui valide la révision constitutionnelle
de 2008 ce que je me refuse à faire pour
restaurer les droits du parlement
combattre le déséquilibre institutionnel
actuel il faut élaborer ça j'en suis
convaincu et apparemment il ya débat
dans la gauche un autre projet
constitutionnel dans la perspective des
échéances électorales d'ailleurs à venir
qui rendent réellement au peuple et à
ses représentants
leur souveraineté ça ça me paraît
essentiel le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy a démontré la conception de la
démocratie parlementaire en vogue à
l'elysée un parlement aux ordres une
majorité convoqué régulièrement à
l'elysée pour se faire rappeler à
l'ordre
une marche forcée dans les travaux
législatifs bien entendu nous approuvons
tout ce qui peut permettre au groupe de
remplir leur mission
mais nous alertons également sur un
renforcement excessif du travail de
contrôle qui se ferait dans le cadre
actuel au détriment de l'essentiel
il faut voir déjà la façon dont
aujourd'hui nous travaillons
lorsque les auteurs s'interrogent sur le
suivi des finances publiques par exemple
avec mon groupe je m'interroge sur le
recul progressif la participation du
parlement à l'élaboration du budget et
de la loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale
nous avons critiqué la loft qui semble
convenir à tout le monde mais on voit au
fil des années que le par le rôle du
parlement en matière budgétaire est
considérablement amoindri et aujourd'hui
vous proposait d'ailleurs de
constitutionnaliser le fait que le
parlement ne soit plus libre en matière
de décisions budgétaires en matière de
finances publiques ce qui est le droit
essentiel du parlement en le confiant à
bruxelles
donc voyez ça on a quand même des
problèmes de fonds pour renforcer les
pouvoirs des groupes politiques en
matière budgétaire commençons par
supprimer l'article 40
commençons par nous mettre en cause de
l'article 41 aussi de la constitution
bon mais ça ça demande évidemment une
révision
constitutionnel alors pour conclure je
dirais que nous voterons contre
l'irrecevabilité proposée par la
majorité pour les raisons que j'ai dit
c'est que d'une façon la majorité
opposent toujours les recevait souvent
les recevabilité à aux propositions de
loi de l'opposition ce qui lui permet de
ne pas en discuter au fond parce que en
fait il ya un immense chantier
constitutionnel qui est nécessaire pour
démocratiser en profondeur nos
institutions et toute proposition qui se
propose d'améliorer les moyennes des
groupes et donc du parlement méritent
d'être prises en considération parce
qu'elles permettent effectivement
d'ouvrir un débat sur le sujet et on
aurait fort à gagner se trouve à mener
effectivement ce débat voilà je vous
remercie
merci même la présidente la parole est à
madame jacqueline gourault pour l'union
centriste
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
comment permettre aux groupes politiques
de mieux participer aux débats et aux
travaux de notre assemblée et d'y
prendre pleinement la place qui leur
revient c'est la question que pose la
proposition de loi qui nous est soumise
aujourd'hui et je suis chargé de vous
donner la vie du groupe union centriste
alors comme l'ont fait d'autres
intervenants avant moi je dirais
monsieur colin c'est une bonne question
ça commence mal en général quand on dit
ça une question en tout cas qui est au
coeur des débats ou qui était au coeur
des débats lors de la dernière révision
constitutionnelle opérée en 2008
à cette occasion les groupes politiques
ont vu leur rôle s'amplifier se
démultiplier le rôle tout d'abord avec
par exemple droite tirage accordé au
groupe pour la création de commission
denquête ou de mission d'information ou
encore la possibilité pour le
secrétariat des groupes d'assister à
certaines réunions de commissions enfin
la présidence
la présence pardon des présidents de
groupe à la conférence des présidents
renforce d'autant plus l'importance des
groupes que c'est cette même conférence
qui fixe la moitié de l'ordre du jour en
vertu des dispositions nouvelles de
l'article 48 de la constitution et 15
jours de séance par mois est réservée à
l'initiative des groupes d'opposition et
des groupes minoritaires les moyens
ensuite notre collègue monsieur garrec
nous le rappelle dans son rapport
en reprenant en reprenant alors sa
casquette de questeur du sénat
les crédits affectés aux groupes
politiques ont augmenté de plus de 30%
depuis 2008 d avance et donc non
négligeables ont eu lieu ces dernières
années et l'on doit bien sûr s'en
réjouir pour autant il est vrai aussi
que nous ne pourrions que nous pourrions
aller encore plus loin et c'est lady
l'idée défendue par les auteurs du texte
mais mon groupe considère qu' on se
heurte à une question de forme une ppl
était-elle le bon vecteur pour de tels
changements
le groupe pense que non en effet
beaucoup d'éléments de ce débat relève
en réalité du règlement des assemblées
l'article 51 de la constitution renvoie
aux règlements des assemblées et non à
la loi
le soin de déterminer les droits des
groupes politiques
il ne fait d'ailleurs aucun doute que le
malgré le travail intenses et
constructifs mené au sein du groupe de
travail sur la réforme du règlement de
notre haute assemblée ce dernier demeure
aujourd'hui perfectible notre débat me
donne aujourd'hui l'occasion de rappeler
qu'il est nécessaire de poursuivre la
réflexion autour des aménagements et
améliorations possibles de notre
règlement on me propose comme l'a fait
jean pierre sueur de faire quelques
propositions
enfin d'en faire une au moins il paraît
très opportun que le représentant du
secrétariat des groupes puissent être
présents à l'ensemble des réunions de
commissions et notamment à celles
examinant les amendements extérieur
le travail est alors parfaitement le
même que lors de l'élaboration du texte
de la commission
et donc nous comprenons mal cette
restriction sur le fond le test que nous
examinons aujourd'hui repose selon notre
avis sur une erreur de conception du
rôle des groupes par rapport à celui des
commissions en matière de contrôle les
auteurs de ce texte voudrait aller plus
loin en leur reconnaissant des
prérogatives qui appartiennent aux
commissions et à elle seule
là encore la proposition de loi apparaît
contraire à la constitution qui est la
norme définissant les prérogatives des
commissions pour conclure je salue
l'initiative prise par nos collègues du
groupe rdse
car elle nous a permis bien sûr pas de
poser le problème en séance et de parler
du problème du fonctionnement de notre
autre assemblée
mais pour les raisons que j'ai évoquées
précédemment touchant à
l'inconstitutionnalité du texte le
groupe union centriste votera en faveur
de la motion présentée par le rapporteur
dont naturellement j'ai pu apprécier le
travail en commission à propos je vais
rajouter ma petite note personnelle
à propos des changements dans le
règlement qu'on pourrait faire et quand
je vous regarde tous très nombreux ici
présent je me disais que je reviens sur
un de mes dadas qui je sais heureusement
le président jean-jacques pièce n'est
pas là c'est peut-être aussi revoir la
manière de voter dans la haute assemblée
je vous remercie merci madame la
sénatrice la parole est à monsieur
christophe andré frassa pour rattacher
ump
bonjour madame la présidente
ce ministre sur le rapporteur chers
collègues comme vous le savez la
révision constitutionnelle du 23 juillet
2008 de modernisation des institutions
de la vème république a élargi des
attributions du parlement
nous connaissons l'importance des
missions du parlement nous avons
d'ailleurs eu à débattre sur ce sujet au
début de l'année lors de l'examen de la
loi tendant à renforcer les moyens du
parlement en matière de contrôle de
l'action du gouvernement et d'évaluation
des politiques publiques
promulguée par la suite le 3 février
mais la révision constitutionnelle de
2008 a également consacré le rôle des
groupes politiques
il est ainsi inscrit que dans la
constitution que la loi le site garantit
la participation équitable des partis et
groupements politiques à la vie
démocratique de la nation en faisant
ainsi leur entrée dans le texte même de
la constitution le travail des groupes
politiques au parlement a été
institutionnalisée notre collègue yvon
collin a déposé une proposition de loi
tendant à renforcer les moyens de
contrôle et d'information des groupes
politiques de l'assemblée nationale et
du sénat
en ce sens notre assemblée a déjà adopté
plusieurs dispositions le 2 juin 2009
après l'examen d'une proposition de
résolution modificative notre règlement
pour les auteurs de la proposition de
loi le règlement des assemblées
parlementaires ne pouvaient comporter
l'ensemble des dispositions nécessaires
pour que les groupes politiques soit en
mesure d'accomplir leurs missions
institutionnelles
l'objectif recherché est donc de
remédier à cette lacune pour que les
groupes politiques disposent de nouveaux
moyens à l'exercice de leurs fonctions
la législation le contrôle de l'action
du gouvernement et l'évaluation des
politiques publiques
la question à l'origine de cette
réflexion était je cite comment
permettre aux groupes politiques de
mieux participer aux débats et aux
travaux de notre assemblée
et d'y prendre pleinement la place qui
leur revient les réponses apportées dans
cette proposition de loi
c'est là que ça se gâte nous semble
inadapté et contraire à la constitution
comme nous l'a brillamment exposé notre
rapporteur rené garrec
cette proposition de loi pose d'une part
le principe de la participation des
groupes politiques aux missions confiées
au parlement et d'autre part d'otc
groupe de droit et de moyens tendant à
garantir une contribution pleinement
informée à ses missions en prévoyant les
conditions dans lesquelles s'exerce ses
nouvelles prérogatives et en listant
pendant listant un certain nombre
d'autorités et d'organismes qui peuvent
être consultés et ou saisis par les
présidents des groupes politiques de
l'assemblée nationale et du sénat
notre rapporteur nous propose
aujourd'hui d'adopter une motion tendant
à opposer l'exception d'irrecevabilité
que le groupe ump dont je me fais le
porte parole soutiendra pour les raisons
que je vais vous exposer en premier lieu
selon la constitution il revient aux
règlements des assemblées et non à la
loi de déterminer les droits des groupes
et plus particulièrement des groupes
d'opposition est minoritaire en deuxième
lieu le gouvernement dispose de
l'administration selon l'article 20 de
la constitution en prévoyant pour les
groupes un droit d'accès à toute
information nécessaire et l'assistance
de tout organisme la proposition de loi
porte manifestement atteinte au principe
de séparation des pouvoirs en conférant
au groupe des prérogatives à l'égard du
gouvernement des administrations et
organismes qui relèvent de son autorité
le texte repose en troisième lieu sur
une erreur de conception du rôle des
groupes par comparaison à celui des
commissions telles que la réforme du
règlement du sénat de 19,2 2009la prévu
contrairement aux gros politique les
commissions parlementaires ne dispose
pas de prérogatives pour elle même mais
en vue de l'information ou de la
délibération de l'assemblée dans son
entier afin de lui permettre d'accomplir
les missions de législation et de
contrôle qu'elle tient de la
constitution en outre les groupes
politiques ne sont pas les détenteurs du
mandat de leurs membres c'est-à-dire les
représentants de la nation au sens de la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen de 1789
seuls les parlementaires
individuellement réunis en assemblée le
sont dès lors les groupes ne saurait
s'arroger les prérogatives de la
représentation nationale qui sont
attribués aux commission denquête ou
commission permanente en matière de
contrôle ce ne sont pas les groupes
politiques qui ont pour mission de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement mais
bien les assemblées parlementaires
de plus les groupes ne sont pas tenus de
rendre compte de leur activité auprès de
leur assemblée alors que les travaux de
contrôle des commissions font l'objet
d'une publicité les travaux des groupes
demeurent confidentielles comment
considérer dès lors que les groupes
puissent participer à la mission de
contrôle si leur travaux ne sont pas par
principe publiques la publicité des
débats et des travaux est un critère
fondamental des travaux parlementaires
chers collègues vous l'aurez compris
cette proposition de loi se révèle aller
à l'encontre de notre constitution le
groupe ump ne peut donc y souscrire je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le sénateur le sud
ministre
merci madame la présidente
oui je voudrais pas par courtoisie
répondre aux orateurs mais aussi pour
apporter des précisions je regrette que
monsieur sueur ne soit pas là car je
voulais lui lui répondre lui répondre
sur plusieurs points je vais donc éviter
certains éléments de ma réponse pour
être plus rapide mais je voudrais lui
dire que s'agissant des questions et de
abel voilà qui revient je vous accueille
avec plaisir aux sueurs je voulais vous
répondre sur le problème des présidents
et des rapports dans les règles
parlementaires et dans le cas de la
tradition la vème république et une
majorité et une opposition et la
majorité tout naturellement détient les
moyens de pouvoir ce qui est tout à fait
normal en revanche en revanche il est
normal que l'opposition participent aux
moyens de contrôle et c'est bien ce que
les institutions ont permis de faire
dans la révision récente de la
constitution est 7e
cette possibilité donnée à la magie à
l'opposition d'être associés à parts
égales à la majorité pour les moyens de
contrôle me semble une bonne chose je
regrette que vous ne l'ayez pas relevé
c'est pas c'est pas 2 mais monsieur
monsieur sur est-ce que je peux parler
s'il vous plaît dans ce cas là dans ce
cas là ne parlait pas un temps que moi
bien je réponds ce que vous avez dit je
vous réponds également sur la semaine
d'initiative lorsque vous parlez des
navettes qui sentait qu'ils sont
interrompues dans la journée
d'initiative et non pas la semaine de
votre groupe
personne n'empêche que le groupe
socialiste de l'assemblée puisse prendre
la proposition que vous avez fait voter
ici pour la faire voter dans notre
hémicycle il s'agit simplement là aussi
que la règle majoritaire s'applique il
ya une majorité il y à une minorité et
on ne peut pas contester le fait que la
majorité puisse effectivement dire oui
ou non à certaines propositions
je voulais surtout vous répondre parce
que tout à l'heure vous m'avez mis en
cause personnellement et je trouve ça
peu courtois de votre part qui pourtant
avait l'habitude de l'être de lettres de
l'être très régulièrement courtois
d'abord
d'abord vous m'avez dit que c'est par
les 15000 deux mois la proposition sur
la laïcité aurait pu la terminer
c'est faux parce qu'ils manquent et
quarante minutes pour qu'elle le soit
j'ai le décompte précis des orateurs qui
avaient encore à parler et je vois pas
comment vous auriez pu faire passer
quarante minutes dans l'es15
malheureuses minutes pendant lesquelles
j'ai parlé donc je vous remercie de
reconnaître que j'ai raison monsieur
sueur je vous remercie de reconnaître et
j'ai raison et je dirais même plus que
ce que vous dites ce que vous dites me
donne l'occasion de dire que si hier le
groupe socialiste n'est pas fait ce
qu'il a fait sur la proposition de
l'euro 2016 c'est à dire utiliser les
quatre heures de temps de toute la
matinée
eh bien nous aurions pu hier d'après
midi par dont nous aurions pu hier
ce lyon puis hier étudier la proposition
sur l'identite approprié de la
protection de l'identité
alors vous voyez que les arguments pour
se retourner contre ceux qui les
opposent
maintenant bordeaux je ne peux être je
ne peux être un accord avec vous vous
l'avez compris vous le savez par avance
avec votre approche de la constitution
de la vème république
pas plus d'abord que je ne peux être non
plus en accord avec votre critique de la
règle dite de l'entonnoir issu de
l'article de la constitution
elle n'est pas excessive cette règle
d'entonnoir elle vise et opportune je
trouve au contraire parce qu'elle vise à
rapprocher les points de vue des deux
assemblées en évitant une obstruction
volontaire une multiplication à l'excès
des amendements qui réitère des
amendements déjà déposés et elle est de
toute manière très démocratique et
parlementaire s'exprimer je ne peux pas
être d'accord avec vous je terminerais
que madame madame gouraud qui qui a qui
a effectivement madame gros que je tiens
à remercier
merci madame gros d'avoir soutenu la
position du gouvernement et du président
et du rapporteur de la commission
je suis bien sûr tout à fait d'accord
avec vos arguments
je suis donc pas y revenir car vous
partager exactement les notes monsieur
fera ça vous aussi
le tiens à vous remercier de votre
position car vous souligner la
pertinence de des argumentations que
nous avons développée sur lesquels cette
proposition sans vouloir donner de
nouvelles pratiques prérogatives aux
groupes politiques qui créerait vous
avez assisté sur ce point une confusion
avec celles qui sont à l'évidence c'est
tout à fait légitime celle des
commissions permanentes
donc cessons des raisons supplémentaires
s'il fallait en trouver de voter
l'exception d'irrecevabilité que le
rapporteur va défendre maintenant merci
beaucoup monsieur le président non ah
bon alors nous passons à la discussion
de la motion tendant à opposer
l'exception d'irrecevabilité qui a été
déposée au nom de la commission des lois
la parole est à l'auteur en fait à
monsieur le président si ce que c'est
une proposition de l'exception de la
corse de la commission au nom de la
commission
je considère que après le débat très
longtemps nous avons eu sur ce sujet et
qu'on pourra prolonger dans d'autres
dans d'autres termes je le crois je
colle à l'exception est défendu je
rappellerai simplement une chose on
on parle des pouvoirs des commissions
parle des pouvoirs des groupes mais il
ya un pouvoir essentiel c'est le pouvoir
individuel du parlementaire eh oui
c'est tout à fait fondamental aussi dans
les institutions de la république et je
crois qu'il ne faudrait pas non plus les
oubliez donc l'exception est défendue
pour permettre l'examen de la deuxième
proposition de nos collègues du groupe
rdse un orateur contre la motion c'est
le président colin dur après midi ça
devrait même la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
ainsi la commission des lois a fait le
choix de couper court
la discussion d'une proposition de loi
d'importants dons portant le rapporteur
de la commission mais je l'en remercie
admis que sur le fond notre texte pose
de bonnes questions
elle lui paraissait d'ailleurs si bonne
qu'ils suggèrent aux auteurs de la
proposition de loi de solliciter la
réunion d'un nouveau groupe de travail
sur le règlement du sénat ou encore de
présenter une proposition de résolution
tendant à modifier le règlement en vue
d'attribuer des droits supplémentaires
au groupe politique aussi si problème il
ya il est ainsi particulièrement
regrettable que notre commission des
lois plutôt que de contribuer à
améliorer un texte perfectible quel
texte ne l'est pas destiné à les
résoudre décide de déclencher le coup
près de l'exception
d'inconstitutionnalité
elle vous propose ainsi d'user d'une de
ces procédures de notre droit
parlementaire qui lui confère une
violence particulière puisqu'il s'agit
d' autodétruire le rôle même du
parlement
or ceci est fait sur des bases si
contestable et à l'appui d'un refus
d'élargir et droit parlementaire option
pour le moins paradoxal
venant d'une commission parlementaire
comme peut s'interroger sur les motifs
de la commission on peut se demander si
dans la révision constitutionnelle
ce n'était point de temps ces
dispositions qui vous plaisait que ce
qui manquait c'est à dire la définition
d'un statut de l'opposition
car si la très bénigne reconnaissance
légale de pratiquer à vrai dire évidente
pour quiconque réfléchir nécessité du
mandat du tout parlementaire et que vous
reconnaissez d'ailleurs comme tel
puisque vous évoquez dans votre rapport
l'existence de dispositions satisfaite
par le droit en vigueur vous jusqu'au
point d'estimer que notre constitution
essentiellement parlementaire en serait
violente et que dire à l'actuelle
majorité
quand le temps sera venu de moderniser
enfin est vraiment notre parlement pour
que ces travaux prennent toute l'ampleur
que le peuple français attend le
parlement n'est pas populaire monsieur
le président vous invoqués à l'appui de
ce jugement trois dispositions
constitutionnelles
pas moins premièrement vous dit
premièrement dites-vous il eût fallu en
passer par le règlement seul compétent
selon vous pour déterminer les droits
des groupes politiques en tête de
l'article 51 de la constitution
deuxièmement la proposition de loi
porterait atteinte à l'organisation des
pouvoirs fixée par la constitution
troisièmement elle violerait le principe
de séparation des pouvoirs je demande à
l'assemblée et je le lui demande
pour préserver ses droits de ne retenir
aucun de ces arguments
sur le premier point je crois qu'on peut
admettre que l'article 51 1 de la
constitution ainsi d'ailleurs que son
article 48 se traduit par une
reconnaissance et des groupes
parlementaires dans notre droit positif
constitutionnel je crois qu'on pourrait
même à partir des pratiques
parlementaires de notre république et
des règlements des assemblées hisser au
rang des principes généraux reconnu par
la loi de la république
cette reconnaissance des groupes
politiques parlementaires
quoi qu'il en soit le rôle éminent
reconnu au groupe à la fois dans le
fonctionnement interne des assemblées
mais aussi comme contributeur à
l'exercice de leurs missions
constitutionnelles suffit à fonder sans
même qu'il soit nécessaire de se référer
à l'article 51 m l'ouverture de droits
correspondant à leur implication dans
l'exercice des dix missions en revanche
dès lors que ces droits ne concerne pas
exclusivement ni même principalement
l'organisation interne des assemblées je
ne crois pas que les règlements des
assemblées parlementaires puissent
offrir conditionnement le support de
leur définition comme les
reconnaissances de droit que comporte
notre proposition de loi sont opposables
en principe à des tiers nous avons ainsi
pris soin d'en passer par la loi et de
ne pas empiéter au demeurant sur le
terrain de la loi organique vous l'avez
remarqué sur l'organisation des pouvoirs
je serais bref notre proposition de loi
ne retranche rien aux pouvoirs des
organes internes du parlement elle ne
donne aucun nouveau pouvoir aux groupes
politiques elles se contentent de leur
ouvrir des droits leur père métal
simplement de fonctionner dans le cadre
des prérogatives que leur confère notre
constitution et nos usages république
ces droits sont strictement
proportionnées aux fonctions reconnu au
groupe
au demeurant en pratique l'existence des
groupes politiques est traversé par un
certain nombre de ces conférences ou de
collaboration avec des tiers dont nous
prévoyons la reconnaissance légale sans
qu on s'offusque de leurs éventuels
contravention nouvelle organisation des
pouvoirs
enfin pour terminer sur la violation de
la séparation des pouvoirs je dirais
d'abord qui ne fait aucun doute dans
notre esprit que les groupes
parlementaires ne sont pas des pouvoirs
publics constitutionnels
on pourrait d'ailleurs à ce titre mais
nous l'avons jamais dit à ce nom on
pourrait d'ailleurs à ce titre argué que
votre réception d'inconstitutionnalité
membres sur ce point de tout objet mes
chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris je vous demande de
rejeter l'exception
d'anticonstitutionnalité présenté par la
commission des lois m
me paraît pas fondée elle aurait pour
effet d'empêcher le parlement de trouver
des solutions à ce que la commission
reconnaît être un vrai problème
je vous remercie de votre attention y at
il des demandes
l'explication monsieur sueur madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je ne vais pas reprendre
les arguments que j'ai exposé pour
plaider contre cette exception
d'irrecevabilité mais je voulais
simplement à la faveur de cette
explication de vote
faire une mise au point à la suite des
propos de monsieur le ministre monsieur
le ministre il n'était nullement dans
mon intention de faire une attaque
personnelle si peu que cela fût à votre
égard je prenais simplement l'exemple de
la séance de ce matin pour souligner un
caractère quelque peu paradoxale de
notre organisation pour les semaine
d'initiative parlementaire
en effet il peut arriver que le débat
sur une proposition dure très longtemps
hier ce fut le cas en raison du droit
qu'ont les parlementaires y compris ceux
qui font partie de l'opposition si la
proposition relève de la majorité où l'
inverse de s'exprimer c'est bien naturel
et à partir de ce moment là il peut se
trouver que pour une raison qui n'est
pas du tout de son fait
un groupe qu'ils soient de la majorité
ou de l'opposition se trouvent privés
d'une débat ou d'un parti d'une partie
de débat donc j'ai eu tort sans doute
monsieur le ministre de citer
particulièrement votre propos d'ailleurs
sous le regard attentif comme toujours
de madame la présidente catherine tasca
je sais que d'autres ont contribué à
l'inflation et que donc chacun a
contribué à ce que cette proposition de
résolution sur la laïcité ne put pas
être votée ce que pour ma part je
déplore beaucoup et j'appelle simplement
de
veux et je ne met personne en cause une
réflexion dans nos rangs et peut-être au
sein des instances du sénat sur
l'organisation de ces semaines compte
tenu de l'expérience qui est la nôtre
depuis quelques mois c'est simplement ce
que j'ai voulu dire je vous remercie
nous allons passer au vote de la motion
dire de l'exception d'irrecevabilité
déposée par la commission des lois
j'ai été saisi d'une demande de scrutin
public par le groupe ump
nous avons deux avis favorable de la
commission et du gouvernement
il va donc être procédé au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du règlement ceux qui
souhaitent voter pour vos mettront au
scrutin bulletins blancs ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre mettront un but
d'un bleu ceux qui souhaitent s'abstenir
remettront un bulletin rouge le scrutin
sera ouvert dans quelques instants
bonjour oui ouvert
sookie
mu est clos j'invite mesdames et
messieurs les secrétaires a procédé au
dépouillement du scrutin
999 sur la motion tendant à opposer
l'exception d'irrecevabilité à la
proposition de loi tendant à renforcer
les moyens de contrôle et d'information
des groupes politiques nombre des
votants 338 nombre des suffrages
exprimés
338 majorité absolue des suffrages
cent soixante dix pour l'adoption 182
contre 156 le sénat a adopté l'exception
d'irrecevabilité dont l'effet est
d'entraîner le rejet de la proposition
de loi
nous quittons l'hémicycle du sénat merci
à vous d'avoir suivi cette séance
prochain rendez-vous avec l'actualité
parlementaire c'est cet après midi à
partir de 19 heures avec le journal
présenté par pierre henri gergonne très
belle journée à tous